ever since the thrilling first trailer
for the batman hit the internet
fans across the world have spent
countless hours combing through every
last shot
hoping to decipher some of the trailer's
fascinating riddles here's an
in-depth look at this teaser broken down
moment by moment
putting aside the usual studio logos and
the inevitable revamped version of a
classic rock song
the first teaser for the batman opens up
with the unnerving sound of unraveling
duct tape
and a few glimpses of a nearly
unrecognizable version of the riddler
wrapped in a bottle green trench coat
and clad in a mask and dark goggles
this is a pretty unsettling and totally
unprecedented interpretation
of batman's puzzle-loving enemy in place
of the goofy
slapstick character many have come to
associate with edward nigma
nashton the batman's riddler appears to
be a
colder more calculating kind of serial
killer more akin to the antagonists of
zodiac or
seven than whatever this was
then there's the riddler's victim a dead
man in a chair
smothered by duct tape upon which the
killer has spelt out the words
no more lies in ominous blood red
letters
all signs point to this poor sap being
don mitchell jr
gotham's mayor whose death kicks off the
movie's plot
but just why is this killer targeting an
elite politician
and what will be the after effects of
mitchell's death on the city itself
well that's one riddle that has yet to
be solved
after offering up that first glimpse of
the riddler the trailer cuts to jim
gordon walking down an office hallway
flanked by some very worried looking fbi
agents and gotham police
officers that's because batman is on the
scene too
and it's clear his relationship with the
police is a tenuous one indeed
matt reeves has pointed to mike w barr's
batman year 2
as one of the primary comic book
influences for this movie so
unlike many previous batman films the
story for
the batman focuses on the early years of
his vigilante career
at only a year and a half into his role
as batman bruce wayne has yet to figure
out his place in gotham
or how to implement the change he
envisions for his city
not to mention whether to establish a
positive working relationship with the
gcpd
as it stands batman is more of an urban
legend at this point than a renowned
caped crusader
and so his appearance strikes fear into
the hearts of everyone
including the city's police force after
all at this point he's basically just a
violent weirdo in a suit
and not everyone is going to be happy to
see him eagle-eyed viewers will have
noticed a number of clues appearing over
the course of the next few shots
which depict police investigators
examining the crime scene
one of the more notable being the
victim's hand shrouded by a brown paper
bag
for some unknown reason framed newspaper
clippings also line the office walls
all defaced in a manner similar to the
victim's body with the word lies
written in what appears to be blood you
can pretty much assume that this
is the office of mayor mitchell who
according to the clippings
has recently won an unprecedented third
term
over an opponent named bella royale a
political adversary of mitchells who
in the batman is said to be played by
jamie lawson
belarus is most likely a brand new
character to the dc universe
but some fans have theorized that the
name could be a cover for someone more
recognizable
such as barbara gordon otherwise known
as batgirl
considering her name really does sound
like a red herring and the fact that
barbara gordon did run for political
office in the comics
there's every chance these fans are
right or maybe they're not
and bella rael is just a new character
after all only time will tell
it's possible to glean a little more
information from the other headlines
plastered on mitchell's walls
most notably the mention of a drug bust
involving
somebody called maroney as any batman
fan will tell you
salvatore moroni is a longtime batman
villain who
in the comics is most famous for being
the one who throws acid into harvey
dent's face
turning him into the iconic villain
known as twoface this newspaper clipping
seems to confirm that moroni also
exists in reeves batman universe and may
even make an appearance in the batman
although nobody has confirmed to play
the character just yet
but what role might he have in the story
well since reeves has made it clear
this murder mystery will focus on the
deep-seated corruption in gotham city
it's possible that the so-called lies
highlighted by the riddler
could bring to light a connection
between the former mayor and the city's
local mob bosses
the moroni mafia are mortal enemies with
their rivals
the falcone family which is headed by
carmine falcone
and it could be that the mayor made a
deal with falcone to bust the moroni's
and eliminate the gangsters black market
competition
unlike moroni carmine falcone is
definitely set to appear in the batman
played by john tatura so gotham's
criminal kingpins
certainly have some role to play in the
movie's plot
by far the most important clue left at
the riddler's crime scene
is the card planted on mayor mitchell's
body its vibrant green envelope
is a nod to the villain's iconic outfit
from the comics
and provides a reminder of the stark
contrast between the character's
colorful origins
and reeve's new noir interpretation on
the front of the card there's a colorful
halloween themed image
complete with a playful skeleton fat and
owl the owl can most likely be
interpreted as a pointed reference to
the court of owls
a secret organized crime group with deep
ties to gotham's elite
including the wayne family if the court
is connected to the film's plot
bruce is likely to discover some
disturbing truths concerning his own
family's past
which could find him questioning his
parents own involvement in gotham's
corruption
the card's holiday theme may also be a
reference to another inspiration for
reeves
batman the long halloween a 13-issue
comic book series which centers around a
conflict between
you guessed it salvatore moroni and
carmine falcone
any of this mean anything to you
as you might expect considering who's
behind this crime there's a riddle
written inside the card left on
mitchell's body
what does a liar do when he's dead
alongside this cryptic question
are a series of mysterious glyphs that
according to a number of internet
sleuths reveal the answer to the card's
riddle he lies
still this simple yet dark pun fits
perfectly with the riddler's mo
and provides a little insight into the
character's own perspective on the world
according to the riddler a liar is
perfectly capable of deception
long after their death unless of course
the living do something to rectify it
the simplest explanation behind this
riddle is that the dead liar in question
is mayor mitchell but who knows
considering the note is addressed to the
batman there's a good chance it has
implications reaching far back into the
caped crusaders past
or even bruce wayne's moving on from the
riddler's crime scene
the trailer shows a press conference
most likely concerning mitchell's death
being held by the gotham city police
department and the man just
off to the left is actually a legacy
batman character
police chief mckenzie bach as played by
chernobyl's khan o'neal
this canon character first came to
prominence in the dc comic book series
no man's land
in which he's depicted as a rogue
anti-hero and dirty hairy type
who goes by the nickname hardback earned
for his voracious reading appetite
in the no man's land storyline bach
splits with gotham city police
department
only to form alliances with criminals
like oswald cobblepot
in an effort to aid a post-apocalyptic
gotham this sets an
interesting context for o'neill's
character who has never before appeared
in a live-action batman movie
speaking at the conference is
commissioner peter savage who stands
behind a cluster of gcpd officers
a distraught looking gordon and a crying
woman dressed in black
most likely mayor mitchell's grieving
wife meanwhile
a shadowy bruce wayne watches silently
from afar
is he just keeping tabs on the aftermath
of mitchell's death or could he be
scoping out a potential enemy in chief
bach
and his colleague commissioner savage
after spying on box press conference
batman departs on a motorcycle and pulls
up to a cavernous
damp and poorly lit space littered with
various pieces of computer tech and
fabrication equipment
it appears that this is an underground
room akin to a
proto bat cave with the barely visible
words wayne terminal
etched into the overhead stone archway
this location raises a number of
questions
first just where is it is this place
some sort of abandoned
subway station once operated by the
waynes and does its damp appearance link
it to the stalled
seawall construction mentioned in one of
the newspaper clippings on mayor
mitchell's walls
bruce would certainly have the power and
wealth to halt construction on a project
such as
gotham seawall which might have
interfered with his secret base of
operations
plus an abandoned subway linking to an
underground network beneath the city
would certainly be an ideal way to
travel throughout gotham in a stealthy
and efficient manner
this might not be quite as conventional
a batcave as we've seen in other batman
movies
but it would definitely be a fascinating
new take on an iconic comic location
arguably the best set piece in the
trailer is mayor mitchell's funeral
which takes place in what appears to be
gotham city cathedral
bruce wayne is in attendance along with
dozens of other mourners
and inevitably things go wrong pretty
quickly when a black suv
crashes through the church doors almost
killing a young boy standing directly in
its path
the car is covered with the letters doa
written in spray paint
which seems to be the riddler's idea of
a sick joke
referencing the medical term dead on
arrival out of the vehicle steps an
unfortunate hostage with a cell phone
taped to one hand
an explosive device strapped to his neck
and yellow envelope
addressed to batman duct tape to his
chest later in the trailer
batman is seen in the now evacuated
church attempting to save the doomed man
while a bomb disarming robot stands by
only for the bomb to explode in a
massive fireball
throwing batman backwards in the process
can't win them all bats
catwoman is a quintessential character
in any batman development story
and sure enough selena kyle will be a
pivotal part of this film
played by zoe kravitz catwoman is first
glimpsed
breaking into a safe at the scene of
mayor mitchell's death
whether she is working independently or
in cahoots with other criminal parties
is yet to be revealed
but don't be surprised if selena prefers
to forge her own path
rather than throwing in with the others
later in the trailer
catwoman has a physical altercation with
batman which long time fans will
doubtless recognize as the equivalent of
flirting for these particular frenemies
reeves has stated that all of the
movie's iconic characters will be
finding their footing during the batman
meaning heroes and villains alike will
feel a little unrefined
as they're still in the midst of
discovering their true natures
so not only will batman be struggling to
make his mark on gotham city
but selena kyle herself may not have
formally ironed out her catwoman
identity
not just yet at least the teaser for the
batman
then leads to a rainy night outside a
building bearing the sign
gotham recycling city of gotham
sanitation east side depot
here colin farrell's oswald cobblepot is
standing alongside other criminals in an
apparent meeting
while batman watches from afar as many
fans have pointed out
farrell's prosthetics and makeup make
him look practically unrecognizable
so much so in fact that jeffrey wright
reportedly once confused his co-star for
a complete stranger
cobblepot's meeting at the sanitation
depot would imply that he has ties to
carmine falcone
since the docks in that area are likely
involved with the mobster's business
as a result you could make a pretty safe
bet that the penguin will somehow be
involved in the corruption that's
plaguing gotham city
which could even make him a target for
the riddler himself a little later the
trailer cuts back to a shootout at the
sanitation depot between two groups of
men
one of which is led by an enraged
cobblepot
what exactly goes down there has yet to
be seen but let's be honest
it's probably going to be more than a
little shady
in his quest to become gotham's greatest
defender bruce wayne has mastered the
art of hand-to-hand combat
making him quite a mess to tangle with
in a corner this is a lesson a group of
street thugs learned the hard way during
the first
teaser for the batman interestingly
these bad guys all have painted faces
which could have any number of
implications for the movie's story
the obvious connection is that two of
these thugs in particular bear more than
a passing resemblance to the joker and
two face
which might suggest they're paying
homage to these iconic gotham villains
of course the similarities here might
just be little more than easter eggs
they also look a little like the royal
flush gang a group of playing card
themed bad guys who batman has faced
a handful of times in the comics most
likely however the gang's painted faces
are a reference
to the dia de los muertos which would
tie into the batman's supposed links to
the long halloween
whatever their origins one of the thugs
squares up to batman
taunts him and immediately has the ever
living bejesus kicked out of him as a
response
as the rest of the gang watches in
terror batman rises from the ground and
delivers that
immediately iconic line i'm vengeance
reeves vision for the batman offers up a
unique take on gotham's heroes and
villains in a number of ways
and this sequence is a good example of
how such raw displays of batman's rage
are rarely seen in live
action adaptations instead mostly
remaining restricted to the comic books
or
animation it's honestly not an
exaggeration to say that most people
have never before seen
a batman quite like this the tension
between batman and gotham's police force
is a repeated theme in dc comics
in the canon material it takes years for
batman to cultivate a sense of trust
with jim gordon during the latter's
ascension to the commissioner of the
force
while the majority of the gcpd remains
skeptical of best
once batman has his trust however gordon
remains a tireless conduit between
gotham's police and the shadowy
vigilante who stands outside the law
from the looks of it this aspect of
their relationship between gordon and
batman will be a key part of the batman
as the trailer shows gordon
de-escalating a fight between batman and
a group of officers
and this clearly isn't the only time
bruce has run into trouble with the law
a later scene shows batman escaping up a
stairwell with his grappling hook
as gunfire rings around him from police
officers below
batman's conflict with the gotham city
police department may have something to
do with his
unveiling layers of corruption within
the police department
and this theme will carry on beyond the
movie too as it should form the basis
for the spin-off prequel series slated
to air on hbo max
the as yet unnamed show is inspired by
batman year one
and will expand upon the film's
examination of corruption in gotham city
gordon's relationship with his fellow
officers and his blossoming bond with
batman himself
of course a batman movie couldn't be a
batman movie without the batmobile
and sure enough this trailer delivers a
few early glimpses at reeves vision for
batman's legendary car
the batman's version of the batmobile
features gorgeous body lines reminiscent
of classic
old-school detroit muscle cars and is
powered by a gloriously insane
rear-mounted turbine engine which spits
white-hot flames from the rear
the frame has been modified into a
race-quality tube chassis
wrapped in a custom paper-thin sheet
metal body with a vented front hood
this car is as hot and angry as a young
bruce wayne's unbridled
wrap so it's little wonder that it's
been such a hit with fans so far
the latter part of the batman's teaser
trailer poses another question from the
riddler who asks
if you are justice please do not lie
what is the price for your blind eye
this rhyming riddle again suggests that
batman will have to take a long hard
look at some of the issues that hit
close to home
perhaps including his own family's
corrupt past as the trailer winds down
we hear a brief segment from an
interaction between batman and the
riddler
aside from the obvious plot implications
this moment harkens back to some other
influences from the comic books
including darwin cook's brilliantly
insightful batman ego
here just like in the best comics and
adaptations bruce appears to be
genuinely haunted
smeared with black eye makeup his eyes
pierce the screen with all the
melancholy anger that fans have come to
expect from the world's greatest
detective
and that's the end of it the batman is
still in production so there's a heck of
a lot more of this movie that has yet to
be seen
but there's still an awful lot for fans
to unpack and what little this teaser
has shown
for more answers to this movie's mini
riddles you're just going to have to
wait it out
until october 1st 2021 you know what
they say
patience is a virtue check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you